Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Mucho antes del primer selfie,
los antiguos griegos y romanos
tenían un mito
sobre alguien demasiado obsesionado
con su propia imagen.
En una narración,
Narciso era un chico apuesto que errante
por el mundo busca alguien a quien amar.
Tras rechazar a una ninfa llamada Eco,
vislumbró su propia imagen
reflejada en un río,
y se enamoró de ella.
Sin poder apartarse de su imagen,
Narciso se ahogó.
Una flor marcó el lugar donde murió,
y la llamamos narciso.
El mito capta la esencia del narcicismo,
una autocomplacencia excesiva
y a veces perjudicial.
Pero no es solo un tipo de personalidad
que aparece en las secciones de consejos.
Es un conjunto de rasgos clasificados
y estudiados por los psicólogos.
La definición psicológica de narcisismo es
una imagen de sí mismo inflada y pomposa.
En cierta manera, los narcisistas
creen que tienen mejor aspecto,
que son más inteligentes,
y más importantes que otras personas,
y que merecen un trato especial.
Los psicólogos reconocen dos formas de
narcisismo como rasgo de personalidad:
el narcisismo grandioso y el vulnerable.
También hay un trastorno narcisista
de la personalidad,
una forma más extrema,
a la que volveremos en breve.
El narcisismo grandioso
es el más familiar,
y se caracteriza por la extroversión,
el dominio,
y la búsqueda de atención.
Los narcisistas grandiosos
buscan atención y poder,
a veces como políticos,
famosos,
o líderes culturales.
Claro, no todos los que buscan estas
posiciones de poder son narcisistas.
Muchos lo hacen por razones
muy positivas,
como alcanzar el pleno potencial,
o ayudar a mejorar
la vida de las personas.
Pero las personas narcisistas
buscan el poder
por el estatus y la atención
que conllevan.
Mientras que los narcisistas vulnerables
pueden ser tranquilos y reservados.
Tienen un fuerte sentido de suficiencia,
pero se ven amenazados
o menospreciados fácilmente.
En cualquier caso, el lado oscuro del
narcisismo aparece en el largo plazo.
Los narcisistas suelen actuar
de forma egoísta, por lo que
los líderes narcisistas pueden tomar
decisiones arriesgadas o poco éticas,
y las parejas narcisistas pueden
ser deshonestas o infieles.
Si ven desafiada la visión
edulcurada de sí mismos,
pueden volverse resentidos y agresivos.
Es como una enfermedad en la que
los enfermos se sienten muy bien,
pero sufre la gente
que está a su alrededor.
Llevado al extremo,
este comportamiento se clasifica
como trastorno psicológico
llamado trastorno narcisista
de la personalidad.
Afecta del 1-2 % de la población,
más comúnmente a los hombres.
También es un diagnóstico
reservado a los adultos.
Los jóvenes, especialmente los niños,
pueden ser muy egocéntricos,
pero esto podría ser una
parte normal del desarrollo.
La quinta edición del Manual
diagnóstico y estadístico
de la Asociación Estadounidense
de Psiquiatría
describe varios rasgos asociados con el
trastorno de la personalidad narcisista.
Incluye una vista grandiosa de sí mismo,
problemas con la empatía,
sentido de suficiencia,
y necesidad de admiración o de atención.
Lo que hace de estos rasgos un verdadero
trastorno de personalidad
es que toman el control de la persona
y le causan problemas significativos.
Imagina que en vez de cuidar
de tu pareja o de tus hijos,
los usaras como fuente
de atención o admiración.
O imagina que en vez de buscar
retroalimentación constructiva
sobre tu rendimiento,
le dijeras a quienes intentan ayudarte
que están equivocados.
¿Cuál es la causa del narcisismo?
Los estudios en gemelos muestran
un fuerte componente genético,
a pesar de que no sabemos
qué genes están implicados.
Pero el entorno también cuenta.
Los padres que ponen a sus hijos
en un pedestal
pueden fomentar el narcisismo grandioso.
Y los padres fríos y controladores pueden
contribuir al narcisismo vulnerable.
El narcisismo también parece ser mayor
en culturas que valoran
la individualidad y la autopromoción.
En Estados Unidos, por ejemplo,
el narcisismo como rasgo de personalidad
ha ido en aumento desde los años 70,
cuando el foco comunitario de los años 60
dio paso al movimiento de la autoestima
y a un aumento del materialismo.
Las redes sociales han multiplicado
la posibilidad de autopromoción,
pero vale la pena señalar
que no hay evidencia clara de que
las redes sociales causen narcisismo.
Más bien, brindan un medio para que los
narcisistas busquen estatus y atención.
¿Pueden mejorar los narcisistas
en esos rasgos negativos?
¡Sí!
Todo lo que promueva la reflexión honesta
sobre el propio comportamiento
y el cuidado de los demás,
como la psicoterapia o practicar
compasión hacia los demás, puede ayudar.
La dificultad es que puede ser un reto
para las personas con trastorno
de personalidad narcisista
seguir trabajando la automejora.
Para un narcisista, la autoreflexión es
difícil desde un ángulo poco favorecedor.